at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by thrive
market thrive market saves me a ton of
money and it's perfect for these crazy
times thrive market is a
membership-based site on a mission to
make healthy living easy and affordable
for everyone you can regularly save 25
to 50% off of normal retail prices with
member-only prices for anything you can
imagine really whether it's keto paleo
gluten-free vegan whatever you can sort
by that you can find all types of food
you can find supplements you can find
non-toxic home products clean wine dog
food just about anything and let me give
you a personal example of just how much
you can save so my last order
I ordered primal Kitchen mayonnaise
which is made with avocado oil it's
delicious Justin's almond butter and the
first was 25% off the Justin's almond
butter was 30% off raus homemade
marinara sauce which is awesome 26% off
all said and done at the end of my
shopping I saved $39 on my order so
members and I'm a member can earn
wholesale prices every day and save an
average of $30 on each order I'll come
back to that and through thrive gives
their one-on-one membership matching
program every page thrive market
membership is matched with a free one
for a low income family in need and you
can try thrive market a few different
ways they have the monthly membership
which is 995 per month they have the
12-month membership for five dollars a
month which is billed at fifty nine
ninety five and right now this is
exclusive to you guys you can get up to
a $20.00 shopping credit when you join
today now remember that I save
thirty-nine dollars on my order so
basically with one or two orders I pay
for the annual membership which is
pretty sweet so go to thrive market comm
forward slash Tim to give thrive market
a try you
like I said choose between the
membership models you'd like to test out
if it doesn't work for you you can
cancel for any reason within 30 days for
a full refund and on top of that you
will make back your membership and
savings as I have or they give you
credits to make up for the difference so
it's really win-win-win all around and I
would suggest check it out go to thrive
market com forward slash Tim you can
receive up to $20.00 in shopping credit
that's thrive market dot-com forward
slash Tim for up to $20.00 in shopping
credit plus all of the other great stuff
that I mentioned one more time check it
out thrive market dot-com forward slash
Tim this episode is brought to you by
Legal Zoom it's a whole new world out
there and we're all facing new
challenges you may need legal help to
overcome some of yours and that's where
Legal Zoom fits in maybe you've been
wondering about the best way to protect
your family or maybe you're thinking
about starting a business but you don't
know the best way to do it
don't let legal questions hold you back
Legal Zoom has been dedicated to helping
you find the right solutions for nearly
20 years if you're looking to protect
your family with a will or a living
trust or something else or you're
thinking about the right way to start a
business with an LLC nonprofit or more
legal zooms got you covered it's easy to
get started online and if you need
guidance there a network of attorneys
can provide advice to ensure you make
the right choices and since Legal Zoom
isn't a law firm you won't get charged
by the hour let's check it out
visit legalzoom.com today to take care
of the important things that need to get
done
that's legalzoom.com Legal Zoom where
life meets legal
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job to interview and deconstruct
world-class performers to tease out how
it is they do what they do and what you
can possibly model emulate or apply in
your own lives my guest today is David
yarrow why a rrow in his genre David
yarrow is one of the world's
best-selling fine art photographers I
have two collections of his work and one
of them is very very heavy and sitting
about 30 feet away from me right now
most recently David is focused on
capturing the animal in human worlds and
fresh and creative ways which is
probably an understatement you just have
to see some of these images and this has
really been partnered with or coalesced
with philanthropy and conservation those
have been two primary drivers behind his
work in 2019 charitable donations from
the sale of David's images exceeded 2.5
million u.s. Yara's photography of life
on Earth has earned him a large and
ever-growing following among art
collectors and he is now represented by
some of the top contemporary fine art
galleries around the world in the last
two years three of his works have sold
for more than $100,000 each at South
appease auctions in London New York and
UBS have also appointed David as their
global ambassador you can find all about
David and see his work at David euro dot
photography you can see some of his
amazing images on Instagram at David
yarrow that's d-a-v-i-d
why a rrow I highly recommend following
Facebook you can find facebook.com
forward slash David Euro Photography and
then on LinkedIn also david yarrow
pretty easy to find and without further
ado please enjoy this wide-ranging
conversation with yet another guest who
should have their own podcast and it'll
be obvious why that is the case soon
namely david yarrow
David welcome to the show
it's very good to be here it's an older
likewise I'm thrilled to connect I have
several of your large format books of
photography they're both incredibly
gorgeous and incredibly heavy
so in quarantine they're helpful for
doing farmer's carries and but it's
party because Scotland shoplifting is a
problem and we'll get to the current day
but I thought we would start that
initially at the beginning but certainly
some time ago could you please speak to
what happened to you or with respect to
you in Mexico in 1986 sure I traveled to
Mexico for the World Cup in 1986 I was
in my third year out of four at
Edinburgh University studying Business
Studies and economics and my exams were
finished one week into the World Cup and
the day my final exam I flew to Mexico
City had never actually even been to
America before I was working for a very
modest magazine in Scotland that covers
college football which almost by
definition of the very limited
circulation the one benefit the one
benefit of of having that working for
the magazine was that FIFA in those days
would be much more accommodating with
regard to accreditation and just for the
Yanks in our crowd because the FIFA is
like the NFL for football as in actually
using your foot football please continue
and in unlike the the NFL it's been
characterized by blazing corruption for
many years which you're fine NFL hasn't
but putting that to one's it's like the
IOC but the eye sees be blatantly
corrupt as well but this is before
people
knew that FIFA took bungs in order to
give World Cups to places like guitar
and extend Russia but it was 1986 it was
six years six or six months after the
earthquake that are devastated Mexico
City and I arrived as a Scottish fan
first and foremost and they always used
to say the Scottish journalist sir
they're really just fans with
typewriters but I did have I did have an
ax cried it'd have a press pass which
allowed me to go onto the pitch of these
games and and the reality it was that I
was twenty years old I wasn't at all
good I was I was very very average and
also photographing Scotland became very
very difficult because the route was
much more interested watching the game
rather than taking photographs of it and
there was a moment when Scotland were
playing Uruguay and Uruguay had a player
sent off in the first minute of the game
so Scotland had to just to beat ten men
to qualify to the the next round they
were managed at the time by someone I'm
sure a lot of Americans were know Alex
Ferguson whom for many years managed
most United sir alec and there was a
moment when there was a Scottish
center-forward who missed an open goal
and back in The Times newspaper and I
was working them for at the London Times
all they could see was the striker with
his head in his hand and my head also
with where my head in my hands with my
camera nowhere near and they thought
well this guy yarrow he's really not
he's not really focused on the football
at all I the games were a lot of them
were played at midday or at 3 o'clock in
the afternoon because of European TV
time and if you can imagine a hice high
Sun in Mexico and maybe some African
players or Latin American players it was
a great chance that you got very little
facial detail because their faces were
underexposed and then the top of their
heads that are kind of like biblical
halo on top of them but these were the
days in sports photography where in
order to get a moving figure in focus
you had to do a thing called follow
focus because autofocus hadn't been
invented that mrs. Olson the days of
of a film and unfollow focus basically
meant that you moved the ring focusing
rim of the camera in tandem to the
movement of the player so if you had a
player coming towards you like a hundred
meter runner you would try and get as
many different pictures of him and focus
you'd have to move the focal rim
manually and I said it's a trade as a
skill and I was crapping it basically
which meant that they only good pictures
I got were of the players lining up at
the beginning of the match the kids that
were moving too much there was Eva had
another rule that if you are
representing that are qualified for the
tournament every single one of the every
single country that qualified for the
tournament would be allowed one
photographer on the pitch for the final
and Scotland obviously had been the
first team to get knocked out that tends
to happen habitually and of course all
the photographers at our own expense
bills for the newspapers back home had
been sent home with Scotland and then
they would just get their pictures
through ap or Reuters or whatever so I
was left as a 20 year old with a press
pass for the pitch on the World Cup
final and I remember going to the
stadium 6 o'clock in the morning the
game is a midday and I bribed the
Mexican guard with a bit of whiskey
listen listen to me do you mind it's
might one of my rules of the thumb today
whisky everywhere but I said you mind if
I walk from on to the pitch and in those
days the Azteca they had a Monday Night
Football there not too long ago but yes
TECA elder around 120,000 people and he
allowed me just to walk from one goal to
the other and I can see my footprints in
the jus in the grand there's it was a
bit of an epiphany for me I felt well
I'm doing this at 20 this is surely got
to be a big part of my life and you'll
know that the saying from Mark Twain
where he says the two most important
days in a person's life the day they're
born the day they find out why and that
was my first inkling that it might be by
decent part of my life the problem was I
was fetishist
photographer which I think was very
integrity becoming part of parumala I
was lucky had a good final I was in the
right position for the first Argentinian
call and then when marathon is Argentina
one the most extraordinary thing
happened in the probably about twenty or
thirty thousand Argentinians came onto
the pitch and it was just a scrum I had
a big two lenses and two cameras like
most photographers in those days you'd
have one big lens recover in the
midfield area and then a shorter lens
recovering the goldmouth areas and I
thought let's take my wide-angle lens
and try and get as close to Maradona as
possible I might get a picture but it's
gonna in order to be nimble I'm gonna
have to leave that 400 2.8 lens and in
the goalmouth and I just took the split
decision at the time that a lot of
photographers weren't given the number
of Argentinians coming onto the pitch
then it was a gamble worth taking I
thought well let you know if I lose the
equipment as long as I've got close to
Maradona this is the right car and as it
turned out I got dead close to him dead
on to him just as he was lifted on the
another player's shoulders and with the
kind of biblical narrative behind of the
stadium and thousands of people he
looked right in my eyes with it with the
world Karpin of course those were those
are the days in films so you didn't know
what you'd got you didn't know when he
got at sharp he didn't know whether you
got it in the lighting right but I went
back to the net where I'd left my 7,000
which was a lot of money in those days
$7,000 $7,000 of equipment and there was
my lens and my camera and I've always
had a bit of an affinity for
Argentinians ever since that that day
that they were far more interested in
celebrating their never thinking about
making some equipment behind the goal
and if it the picture was picture really
kind of saved my bacon from the whole
tournament it was a photo photography's
is about there's one or two big pictures
is not up to me about portfolios of
hundreds and thank goodness because I
really didn't then
and it led to it led to doing an
Olympics the next year I still had to
finish my my studying and there was the
lovely moment I was flying over to LA
about pattern over six months ago and
the merit on a movie you know it's
directed by the same guy that did this
the earth and Senna movie and Amy - I
thought I should watch this and about
2/3 of the way through the movie which
is excellent my picture came on my TV
screen in front of me and I couldn't
believe it and I don't know about you
but I always get quite emotional on
planes I don't know what it is about our
emotion that's great this is my bloody
photograph that's my photograph of
Maradona so I pressed for the stewardess
because I didn't have anyone to talk to
about it and she came over inspected I
said that's my picture of Maradona and
she's going there's a nutter in j21
there's another and she 20 runs cut him
off no more scotch don't land in Halifax
just yet so we luckily we didn't land in
Halifax and I did have to explain to her
that I was a photographer and that was
that was my picture but I was hoping to
actually go down to be a and see
Maradona and I still very much hoped to
do that when the current crisis is over
it would be quite special to to meet him
and he's got the pitch he knows
obviously knows of the picture and and
and reminisce of when he was the
greatest player in the world amazing so
I wanna I want to add some color for
perhaps the Americans or even just non
Argentines who are listening so Maradona
ma ra do na is a demigod in Argentina it
is hard to overstate how much of a
cultural fixture he is even to this day
and he is certainly decades past his his
prime in playing his his photographs are
everywhere there are murals of him if
you were to take for the US lest you
just say pick your favorite team sport
basketball football Manning American
football
if you were to take the most popular say
ten players in the last decade and
wrapped them into one person that would
be Maradona to Argentines and they take
their their football very very seriously
when I was living there in 2004 of
course good about this yeah you're a
tango dancer your champion tango a long
time ago this is previous life type but
living in Argentina one of the most
terrified moments that I had was waking
up in my apartment building and thinking
that the entire building was on fire
because people were screaming their
faces off at something like 9:00 in the
morning I couldn't recall and it was
because the World Cup was on television
and Argentina scored a goal and they
went completely berserk
you could you could pretty much track
the morale of the country and probably
the GDP based on soccer results they
take it so seriously it is it is hard to
overstate absolutely and of course your
world in his world collide it because
the home of tango was Boca wasn't it but
the baccarat Puentes hour is right he
played for he paid for Boca Juniors
which is one of the two great famous
football clubs in the in the big capital
that's rain bucket pocket in your fans
are very partisan he had a habit of
playing for clubs in cities that are
renowned for wearing it on their sleeve
and for many years he played in Naples
in Napoli in Italy and there was a he
was people would in in in in Napoli they
would have two pictures above their bed
they would have Jesus Christ and Diego
Maradona and when the World Cup was in
Italy two World Cups one World Cup after
the World Cup I photographs the planners
hadn't done a good job because Italy met
Argentina in the semi-final in Napoli
and that for most Neapolitans
constituted an enormous dilemma because
who are they gonna support and they were
gonna give us support
I heard country or were they going to
support there some and the person that
revitalized the city and 75% of the
people in the stadium they were Italian
supported Argentina that yeah what an
incredible story I don't mean to
interrupt but I I want to ask you what
you learned from that experience if
anything what did that what did you take
from that experience after that
photograph hit the wires went everywhere
what what did you take from that or what
impression did that make on you well to
begin with I was just happy that it
saved my bacon because it had diverted
people's attention away from the fact
that 95 percent of the pictures are
taken if the other matches were out of
focus anyways it was it was the outlier
but it gave me a chance and a lot of
these self-help books and and and your
books are at a higher grade than the
majority of them but there is a lot to
be said for it the old idea that if
you're the smartest person in the room
get out of the room so whatever the
polar extreme from being the smartest
person in the room was I was at that
polar extreme in Mexico I was I was the
worst photographer of the British press
corps and that is good because that
means that if you've got any sense of
self pride the only ways up and I just
went back and practiced and tried to get
better the things that I wasn't good at
I think there's a lot to be said in
photography the fact the older older you
get the better you should be as a
photographer those cartier-bresson said
the first thousand pictures you take
will be your worst thousand pictures
that was certainly true of me and the
following year I did I just continued to
work quite a bit in skiing
King was easier to photograph because if
you're doing the men's downhill whether
it be kids bore the the lower horn in or
Aspen or Lake Placid or wherever it
might be
you can pre focus on a gate and then
wait for that skier to come around the
gate so there are there's still lots of
difficulties in it already skiing tenon
I almost remember trying to photograph
the toughest men's downhill in the world
which is the hannam karma kiss book and
that the story is racer in kids poo in
Austria didn't recognize a kids book at
it
Scottish accent but you you do you and
it was the days when you had some
amazing skiers and then you had the
crazy connotes you know the Rob Boyd's
pond or skis they can reads and you
yourself he had Bill Johnson of course
won Olympic gold as well and they were
all crazy mad kid skiers but that first
stretching kiss pool is like the White
Cliffs of Dover a stacked on top of each
other and if you are trying to sidestep
down inside the ropes with 20,000
Austrians outside the ropes going look
at that British idiot he doesn't know
how to ski and he got your long lens
around your neck and your size and he'd
say one bad move and then you're at the
bottom in a heap
so you Yoram getting to be in the
position to take the photograph as part
of the challenge in the first place but
I did it was in the golden era of Swiss
skiing and where there were the men's
and the women's downhill and slalom was
dominated by the Swiss and I got a bit
better at photographing skiing and then
I got the offer to photograph the
Olympics in 1988 and that was in Calgary
in Alberta those Olympics were
remembered for two things firstly one of
the most beautiful women ever to ice
skate called Katarina fit so that's what
most of the photographers that were good
were given to do to spend the evenings
photographing Katarina vet dancing
around a nice ice state in which ice
rink witches
not a bad way to spend the evening in in
1988 the other thing it was remembered
for was the Britain had the world's
worst ski jumper called Eddie the Eagle
and he so they gave that to me because
they thought well that's a good pair up
we'll get yarrow to photograph Eddie the
Eagle and of course anything y'all did
they had a film about him as well quite
recently and they did
Vava didn't do and so i i i joined
calgary and but i had my moment there
where I am in those days the Olympics
would be sponsored the bilasa sponsors
but to the key sponsors would be Kodak
and Fuji that canidates me because we
were still working on film and at the
end of the day you go to these enormous
labs that would be sent up was sponsored
by the by Fuji and Kodak and they you'd
hand in all your 35 mil film you'd hang
around for three hours and then you get
them back and then you'd wore them to
whoever you're worrying them
worrying that no matter how hard I was
trying to get a different type of
picture that I would go around the
editing room because it was those
degrees Photography press photography is
actually quite collegiate in that
everyone tends to try and help each
other
certainly at the top at the bottom
there's there's maybe people were in a
hurry and then the people that are
insecure can be a little bit [ __ ] I'm
sure it's the same in every industry but
you'd I would see too many photographs
that were the same and it worried me
with my very limited understanding of
economics from my schooling the how on
earth could you have a profession that
would evolve if there was just so much
supply of what you were doing you'd go
and try and get a different photograph
of a bobsleigh coming down the bobsleigh
track and then before you knew it there
were 25 German photographers always
watch the Germans they're very good so
they'll be 25 German photographer is
working for stern or whatever they would
have exactly the same or a better image
and I
home from that Olympics full of stories
and I'd love B I love the glamour of it
all and being where the world was
focused to be that men's downhill with
the world watching it was hugely
exciting but I just worried about what
it was all about what my craft what I
was what was I trying to do I was just
getting another picture that perhaps the
world didn't need there was something
else Tim that concerned me that I am I
think a lot of artists are insecure and
I'm insecure it manifests itself in in
lots of different ways I think a lot of
people would see me as not having one
answered insecurity but I do and I worry
about things that I probably shouldn't
do but I had a problem that there was no
one there in the photography world that
was 20 years older than me or 25 years
old of me that I looked up to and I said
I really want to be that man when I'm
older that's what I really want I want
to be him there was no guiding light and
that's not meant to be disrespectful to
any of these individuals who were great
fun in the evenings most of the time but
a lot of them are very dysfunctional
life's and didn't I didn't really see
where the endgame was they were they
were they were Pressman they were
working for either big newspapers or in
those days of course supports
Illustrated was so much of a bigger
magazine that it is now regrettably
but I didn't see many people that were
set a goal for me to try and attain in
terms of getting a job affirmation
getting better what they're doing really
enjoying their life and and taking
pleasure from it there was I think what
a lot of fairly unhappy Pressman and on
on tour and III I remember coming back
from that
Olympics and I had two job offers
because I'd finished my I graduated and
the two job offers were the identical
salary there was a job offer of what
would equate now to $20,000
to work for what is now Getty Images I
wish you'd be familiar with and then
there was an offer of twenty thousand to
work for not West Bank and to the
enormous surprise of people Getty and
but the profound and light of my parents
I chose that West Bank I think they're
both nearly bust now by the way I think
what guesses really well been bought
back by the family because they had to
buy it back after the the private equity
past a parcel but and and now West is
certainly bust why did you choose
NatWest and banking because everyone
else is doing it and I'd watched Wall
Street and I thought Gordon Gekko and
bud Fox were super cool and it was just
as and it was inside there was it was no
it wasn't like minus twenty five in
Calgary it just seemed like what
everyone else was doing way back in
nineteen eighty eight is the Big Bang
and happened and in in the UK that was
when there was a consolidation of the
whole broking industry and Oliver Stone
a produced Wall Street about the about
1985 that a year of 1995 and the books
we read were books like barbarians of
the gays and larvae which is a fantastic
book as an aside and it was RJR nabisco
was new and then a Michael Michael nurse
who just her brighter just brings it
home and I think liars poker were about
the dealing room for Salomon Brothers
you know was was almost like the Bible
if you were whether you sure it's true
in America as well if you'd been at
Harvard or Princeton or MIT and I was
not an Ivy League college like that but
ed Murray University was it was a
certainly a good platform for people
building a career in those days in the
UK and it just seemed the normal thing
to do I'll never forget a conversation
with my father who I had a difficult
relationship he was a kind of
patriarchal Edwardian character that
that was just the way was he didn't mean
it he just that's the way we
of that old-school Downton Abbey type
generation that would never Express
words like love and congratulations or
whatever it'd be very difficult together
to get that kind of appreciation out of
it and I remember him saying to me he
said David you should go into banking
because it's a robust honorable
profession whereas photography is just a
hobby and they kind of dates the
conversation that anyone can say that
because it says well that must have been
in the eighties when someone said that
and my dad was a he was a he was a
industrialist but he was also chairman
of a bank in a kind of ambassadorial way
what does that mean I think that your
banking system and our banking system
are very different in the if you look at
right now if you look at the big the
senior banks that the chairmen of the
banks that are being interviewed right
now during this meltdown and in
financial markets and and talk of
depression they are entirely fluid in
the language of collateralized debt
obligations in credit default swaps if
you're a chairman of a British bank you
just have to be familiar with opening an
envelope and opening an office and my
father's role was very much more there's
a ceremony today someone's got their
50-year give them a watch they've been
working 50 years I don't mean that
disrespectfully but the chairman of
American banks they've got an executive
row and they've could understand exactly
what's going on in terms of their with
risk weighted assets and the risk
portfolio of those assets whereas in the
UK there was a period where you there
were a lot of banks and you could have a
figure at the helm that was just there
to add a little bit of gray hair and
gravitas without having a [ __ ] clue if
I if I if I got my homework done
correctly your your father was involved
banking among other things your he was
he was industrialist he interest so yeah
industrialists Yarra shipbuilders and
then he had the banking involvement your
mother was an artist you end up at after
watching Gordon Gekko reading barbarians
at the gate liars poker all great reads
barbarians at the gate for those people
who don't want to read a book right now
also made into a fairly entertaining
movie you enter the the banking world in
part because it is the normal thing to
do but also because it was I would
imagine at the time based on the the
stories told in these books and shown on
the big screen quite exciting what what
did you learn in banking that informed
your later exploration of photography if
anything I learned so much I learned
failure humility surrounded myself with
bright people and I made a lot of
friends and I think you encourage
younger people these days to remember
that the friendships and and the contact
the people you can call are so important
particularly at times like this when you
need to be calling people and need to
have a degree of context reality you're
right in 1988 going into dealing room
whether it be a Salomon's dealing room
or in my case it was a investment bank
called NatWest markets having five
hundred people in one room was
incredibly exciting he didn't again he
didn't really have a clue what was going
on and someone else was paying for you
to learn
I am I moved to America for a while and
when I was working in Wall Street I got
to meet some of the some of the first
hedge fund managers some of them were in
Boston some of them were in New York and
I thought this is a kind of cool job you
ask you're the guy that can sit around
and not have to make calls the whole
time but maybe be slightly more cerebral
spend a bit more time
just doing your own research and be
judged by the quality of your decisions
not the quantity of your calls the
problem is that no one wanted to harm me
as from manager so I thought in about 19
there was about 1995-96 i I left the
investment bank and set up my own fund
management business I was wasn't married
and didn't have any obligations and I
thought if I don't do it now I never
will and the idea of continuing to be
that bud Fox and plenty of six-figure
numbers on that zip file kind of call
I'd done that for eight years and for
most people it's enough it's a that's a
tough job I do feel and the could the
job is slightly anachronistic now but
that job of being your kind of bud Fox a
Salesman and what will come on to Jordan
Belfort because I spent quite a bit of
time with him over the last twelve
months but it was sunny it's nothing
more elevated water Wall Street who done
yeah that's Jordan Belfort
so I set up my own fund and I didn't
really know I was 31 at the time and the
there weren't there were a few things I
had to negotiate in in the markets but
it wasn't that demanding there was the
way there was the big run in tech stocks
the you'll remember and that in the
towards the tail end of the 1990s
1998-1999
II was a little bitty Kuras the Icarus
why are too close to the Sun years yeah
yeah and then the big Scandinavian
telephony stocks the Nokia's the
Erickson's and then there was the whole
y2k turn of the millennium the situation
oh yeah I often say to people if you get
if you set up a business on Monday and
you get married on a Tuesday
metaphorically
a lot of things are gonna have to go
right in your life for that
decision-making crammed into one kind of
week that albeit wasn't but I I kind of
set up a business on Monday and kind of
got married on a Tuesday in one zanuck
did you get married well I did get
married but it wasn't on the Tuesday but
there wasn't a huge gap between the two
you mean and married
physically merits of yeah but signal
married my girlfriend and got it all
right we here we it so we were and in
2000 we we had she had our first
daughter and everyone looked at me and
said bloody health Yariv not done bad
you've got a got a lovely young family
you got your own business and then in
she was she was barely one one year old
we went over to the America for a
wedding in September 2001 and at the end
of the wedding we said well why don't we
rather than going back to the UK why
don't we just go on a little bit of a us
road trip and on the Tuesday morning I
was getting ready and I was just in a in
the the lobby of the hotel when I saw
the first plane go in or the the what
looks like the the
repercussions of the first plane going
in and of course because it was 215 or
sort of five to two European or British
time our markets were open and I was
running a very very small pot of money
at that time but as I still had
responsibilities I probably had about 60
or 70 investors and I just
since I just didn't like what I saw on
markets who had been tough an away
Ericsson Swedish mobile telephony
company had warned the previous day and
also I was with my wife and I was on a
road trip in America and I thought you
know what this just doesn't look good
and because I'd been I'd read all the
books I just saw water butter I just
take my risk off and because markets
were open so this is now this is on the
day this is on the day and so by the
time the second plane went in we'd
cleared the decks for every client that
we had of every holding that we had I
think Coleman sex I think it was in
those days was still is still now but
they were looking after me they sold
everything that we had and the more if
you go back to those whatever they were
19 minutes or 18 minutes between the two
planes and when one of these CNBC
anchors died two or three years ago mark
Holmes they played hints I thought
extraordinary performance sometimes a
incredibly professional of those 19 20
minutes and what I find still
extraordinary was it it was really only
it 2 minutes before the second plane
went in that things became the firt
there was no impact on the markets at
the first plane going in absolutely none
at all because people just assumed it
was an accident and the whole I'm sure
you remember the visuals of that horn on
the tower it just seemed a bloody big
hole for I'm not trying to be you know
Monday Morning Quarterback but I took
the decision it was there was no skill
and it was just instinct so after the
the whole tournament of 911 and whatever
I went from being someone that was seen
to be a nobody I hasten to add we didn't
make any money from this we just avoided
our clients losing any money so when
they got their returns for the month of
September in the post their return was
not 0.3% where
of course a lot of people had lost 15-20
percent of their money and that's why
the book of Nasim - leaves book full by
randomness plays a big role in my
thought processes I was just lucky but I
went from running a small amount of
money to employing 45 people to running
a billion dollars and over what period
that did that happen about about six
months and six to six to nine months it
was and the reality Tim was I was not
equipped for it
III was not equipped suddenly to be
having a wife a daughter forty five
people a billion dollars whereas wind
back two years e two years before I was
just a kid with a dream and it was
actually too much for me and I couldn't
cope because suddenly everyone wanted a
little bit of my time at home or in the
office and I had to add a lot of
stakeholders in my life I'm not saying
that that's a bad thing I do again now
but I'm more mature I can cope with it
but then I just couldn't and I I just
felt lonely I was felt unhappy and I
didn't know when the when the me time
was there was no real time for me and
when when markets are your way when your
fund is performing through luck or
judgment those cracks can be papered
over in a cocktail of of champagne and
good food and wine and people playing up
to you because you're that you're the
guy but of course as soon as there are
performance deteriorates which
inevitably it will from time to time
those cracks become very conspicuous and
my life kind of blew up I I my marriage
didn't survive i I probably took it out
of myself quite a bit in the evenings
and
what I was thinking I would drink too
much
yeah and I would I think I'd leave it at
that but it was not I don't think I was
that wasn't a happy person then you go
in the following day to to face more
hell and with and also that if you if
you do and so many people do get
divorced sadly but it can its a betters
bigger test as you can have and unless
there was someone the the other side and
you fall in love was somewhere else and
I haven't neither of us were there was
no infidelity was just like ships in the
night two people that were one was being
a mother which is the most important job
in the world
and the other was being a depressed
hedge fund manager were full of the self
and faces ideas that their own
importance potentially and something had
to give and it and it gave and of course
if there is a little bit of money
knocking around because of previous
success well then the lawyers gift to
take their teeth in and all hell breaks
listen I know the the this was all this
is I'm moving forward nodded when the
world really did start financially to
implode which was around the first signs
in 2006 with I think it was the
investment bank Bear Stearns and then
just continued to spiral downwards from
there and because I was going through
the kind of final parts of that divorce
I was had a disposition to being
cautious anyway I just couldn't maybe
subconsciously my whole mindset was to
be cynical and miserable so when and
also something's gotta be wrong I mean
scoffs we requite with quest savvy Bunch
I think that the three oldest
universities in the world are Scottish
from about 1450 but in 2007 a nation of
six million people and we've got to
the top ten banks in the world that
doesn't stack up it's that supple he
might have had three of the oldest
universities and one of the worst
football teams but not like its banks
and so I was I was very cautious about
about that a row back to Scotland bought
one of your banks citizens and it just
it just didn't stack up that these were
where they were in terms of 300 years of
prudence a culture of prudence had gone
to five years of a culture of building
the balance sheet anyway to cut a long
story short we got through 2008 and now
on the I think it was the 8th of
December I had a Christmas lunch with my
team and said we'll listen you know it's
been a shitty time but most people have
had their bollocks put on a plate and
we've lost three or four percent of
people's money so we're gonna come out
of this okay and then for the Yanks just
subtitle bollocks equals balls continue
I'm quite enjoying this yeah please
continue here anyway so I get this phone
calls saying this guy Bernie Madoff
Madoff Madoff has got us handed himself
over to the FBI this biggest Ponzi
scheme and I go who's he and they say
well he runs a big hedge fund out of of
New York I said well it won't affect us
bunch of crooks in this game I knew I
knew about a group of people called
Fairfield Greenwich that were a feeder
to him because this was a this was a
well it was a well known fun but I
thought it had no impact on us and how
wrong was I because what I didn't know
was that so much of the money that had
got invested with Bernie Madoff had also
invested with us and when I set the fund
up in 1997 the only people that are
gonna put money with me where my dog and
my sister so in 1997 I said you can have
your money back in a week's time and I
kept that
from 1900 if you need your money king of
it in a week the next the next day I got
redemptions or the next week of 600
million dollars and that was it that was
that was it so something that I was
exposed to there was an a eggs or genus
variable effectively to all intents and
purposes killed the business and you
asked a question quite a long time ago
it might have been in a previous
millennium but you asked me the question
what what did you learn from investment
from your time in banking I think the
the thing that I took away from it most
was that I must never again put myself
in a position where your Europe your
work ethic can be totally undone by
things be totally beyond your control
it's rather ironic I say this as the
coronavirus is about to hit its peak in
parts of Europe and to hit his beacon in
America soon because clearly that is an
exogenous variable that means that right
now what ideas is not something that
people want to hear an awful lot of bad
but that they'll always remember at that
time it taught me a lot of humility I
think if you're selling a product you
and your career have sold all sorts of
things
and have a huge admiration for the
polymath that you are I've really only
sold two things I've sold hedge funds
and pictures of elephants now by and
large there's a bit more than that but
please continue yeah but by and large
one is quite an easy sell because you
turn around to the guy that wants to
picture the elephant say that's always
gonna be an elephant it's not gonna
you're not gonna wake up tomorrow
morning and it's a giraffe you're
getting what you see whereas the whole
concept of selling a product on the
basis of future returns you cannot
guarantee I really struggled with
and I know I'm not alone but the whole
premise that and the words a Salesman as
well
slightly gives an uncomfortable shiver
down my spine because you shouldn't
really be selling selling investment
products is a very tricky compromise
it's a difficult thing to get right
because you cannot make an aggressive
sell because you cannot guarantee you've
just got to say I promise to do my best
I promise to try and exercise maximum
judgement try not to panic you know I'm
gonna panic or panic early and I'll show
total integrity at all times nothing you
can do more than that but I think it's a
tough I have huge admiration for the
people that do well yesterday on your on
your CMB show one of your icons in hedge
fund management Paul Tudor Jones spoke
and I listened I wrote a master as I
listened so you could hear a pin drop in
in my living room for half an hour and
he was so precise passionate when he
needed to be passionate dispassionate
when he needs to be dispassionate but
all the time entirely considered and but
he's the exception just a quick thanks
to one of our sponsors and we'll be
right back to the show we all shop
online and we've seen that promo code
field that taunts us at checkout you see
it all the time thanks to honey you
never have to manually search for coupon
codes ever again honey is the free
browser extension that finds promo codes
for you and automatically applies them
to your cart as a real example just
yesterday one of my employees save
twenty one dollars that is a whole lot
of money off of a sweater they've been
pining after for a long time here's how
it works just shop at your favorite
sites click the honey button that drops
down and check out and wait a few
seconds as honey scans its database of
all the working coupons for that site
then watch the prices drop that's it
honey has found its seventeen plus
million members more than two billion
dollars in savings so check it out get
honey for free at join honey calm slash
Tim that's join honey
/ Tim so I can't not go down this rabbit
hole for just a second since you
mentioned ptj there are some there's
also a great documentary on his early
days if people can track it down I can't
recall the the name of it right now but
a really sharp guy
and well I'll leave it at that for now
but you know much better than I uh it
just so happens that two of the most
successful photographers I know both
have backgrounds in finance you and
Brandon Stanton who created humans of
New York and yeah that that's that's not
always the case I also know Chase Jarvis
and a few others who do not have finance
or banking backgrounds yeah but but you
in this current set of world
circumstances in lieu of going outside
and photographing elephants and so on
since it's difficult to do that at the
moment I would imagine correct me if I'm
wrong but have have probably been unable
to escape the temptation to put your
investor slash trader hat on at least in
observing world events so so Paul Tudor
Jones has his perspective which as you
noted can be seen on CNBC on the web
there's a two-minute video there's a
longer interview with him he is
reasonably optimistic it's hard to know
how much of that is informed by what his
current book looks like or anything else
but I happen to believe he's a pretty
good guy overall and what do you think
the world looks like in a month three
months six months I know I'm asking you
to kind of look into a crystal ball or
through a turtle shells and so on and so
forth but if you had to speculate what
do you what do you think things look
like whether whether referring to
markets economies or otherwise but what
what is your view of the world and what
do you see coming I've got to be very
very careful that
don't become an instant expert in
viruses because we've seen so many of
those get airtime
recently the first thing I'd say without
wanting to copy what Paul said is that
we are at the end from a financial
markets perspective we're coming to the
end of a first quarter and that always
means that bizarre things happen the
fact that the Dow should have his
biggest run since 1933 at the very time
that New York is being considered the
epicenter of this virus if you're
looking from another planet you really
would think the humans are quite mad
that those two things should happen
simultaneously and I'm sure the history
books will look at what's happened over
the last week it's been a historic week
following a historic week and next week
will be a historic week and just for
timing so we just show where we're
frozen in the amber here we're recording
this on Friday March 27th please
continue so the first thing I'd say is
that I I am following it I want to be an
optimist I want to get out and
photograph I want to Gert and see people
I want to come back to America I want to
go to Africa a couple of things that I
I'm concerned about and Paul touched on
one Africa I'm very concerned about I
spend a lot of time in East Africa a lot
of people turn around to me and say
David you spend you spend quite a bit of
your year in Africa you must love Africa
I turn round
it's like dispersing us they hate Africa
and it's the most corrupt continents in
the world for a start is four continents
wrapped into one whether it be the
Arabic north the already west colonial
East or sub-saharan Africa and the one
thing that unites those four
subcontinent's within the continent is
they're all corrupt from top to bottom
that corruption and lack of
infrastructure is gonna be late very
bear in the next two or three months I
he takes some of the townships in Janice
Berg kidness knows what's gonna happen I
see them made a lot
today but you worry about the spread
you've got to kind of assume that
whether you're in nairobi or dar Salam
or Johannesburg or Lusaka that though no
populations gonna have it that you just
gotta work on that basis the idea of
human distancing and townships I think
you're mutually exclusive so you weren't
you worried about that America is in
many ways the right country for this to
be the epicenter for it to be the
epicenter because your country time and
time again has found a way out of things
and that can-do mentality and ethos has
never been more needed it's also very
good for entertainment factors because
there was the one thing i family i'll do
i just loves it when iiii don't do
politics but the your president's press
conferences are a lot of fun because
when the he's asked a question he you
wouldn't tolerate him on your show Tim
because if he's asked a question he will
he will take the subject matter and then
give his personal experience of the
subject matter so yesterday when he's
asked about when will insurance
protection kick in for second-tier
restaurants he then goes on some sort of
Gettysburg Address except it's not about
we restaurant she gets some really good
meat and fish and then you just get one
bad fish and it ruins all the thirty
good fish you've had and you can where's
this come from because that wasn't what
you're asked but he just takes his
opportunities yes he let go on his own
personal experiences with all the same
addresses and pronouns but that that is
a little bit of light entertainment away
from it I worry for New York I was in
the last American city I was in was New
Orleans two weeks ago in a show there
and that was a better week before the
morning
week after the Mardi Gras and obviously
they're concerned about that city now
we're all fine if I had to put my bed as
good
as bad as anyone elses this is a leaf
how can how can be better than anyone
elses subtly not I I fancy this is six
months and then the claw out the other
side will have many disappointments on
the way when this time yesterday our
European stock markets were around about
15% 16% off their moving average from 12
about 12 weeks ago that seems far too
high now Marcus has been weak today but
that would be my only comment is that
this strikes me if you were looking at
it from another planet this is a 30 to
50% off chorus gasses a vent until it's
sorted and you don't want to be short of
your economy and your economy if we'd
had this conversation two or three
months ago your economy is quite
extraordinary has been extraordinary
we benefit that's why we spend so much
time there we we if you take the second
city in in Great Britain for luxury
spend let's imagine your Tom Ford and
Tom Ford wants to have a new store in
the UK but he's got London say he said
London's fine but where are we gonna go
outside London and he thinks well maybe
should we go to Manchester should we
gonna Edinburgh should we go to leads
maybe Glasgow but then he's probably a
bit stuck after that what I no one knows
what the answer is what that second city
should be what we think is in below
xlviii there are 37 cities in America
that will be stronger than our second
city in the UK and that just shows the
strength and breadth of your economy
which is gonna be tested in the short
term but that less for sure
and I think our to slightly agree with
what Paul said yesterday that you can
see a some stage in the next couple of
weeks
now that the fed have played their cards
that the Lowe's might be retested but
what we do know from the last three days
is there's nothing like a big bear short
squeeze and the speed of that risin
speed of that rise in the markers you
know there are a lot of people that are
short short has market so I think in a
year's time the markets will be higher
than where they are now but we're all
gonna have to go through cutting for
whatever your job is whether you're
running do what you do you do what I do
the next 12 months are gonna be from a
purely cash generation perspective
there's so many other parts to life as
you try and instill in us but purely
from a cash generating perspective the
next 12 months are going to be tough one
or two last questions on this and then
we'll get back to photography cuz I have
a lot of questions about that and
they're cut they're partially informed
by all of this background and context
but if we take one piece of Paul Tudor
Jones video and look at it for a second
I'd love to get your opinion how much
since I don't know the UK markets at all
but how much of the pop that we're
seeing in the US or in the UK do you
think is accounted for by the
front-running that he mentioned of I'm
guessing index funds or other large
institutional's who have to rebalance
effectively right or or forced
purchasing how do you how do you think
about this this current jump you have
that you have the stimulus package
thrown in as another variable and many
other things people covering shorts who
the hell knows but how do you explain
this the the run-up just in the last few
days and at the end of this month I
suppose more broadly yeah
20% is an awful lot to explain by one
variable alone is gonna is gonna have to
be an amalgam an aggregation of
variables so self propagate themselves
but short covering the viciousness of
the Meuse particularly in the last hour
of trading
spank of emotion and machines Ashley I
being I'm saying to totally
contradictory things but emotion of
machines have one thing in common which
is not about considered decision-making
this is not about anyone turning around
and saying I think these numbers in New
York are they're gonna Plateau earlier
or whatever or perhaps they're there
their balance sheets aren't quite as
weak on the worst-case scenario in the
final quarter of this year it is panic
buying to rectify a situation that's not
gonna be comfortable going into the
year-end all right when I am when I got
rid of my fund actually someone took the
fund over and the person that took the
fund over was worse used to work for
another great American's home manager
julian robertson here the tiger fund
management yeah yeah yeah quick quick
side note if people want to know Julian
Robertson's story the the book more
money than God is effectively liars
poker for hedge funds and has some great
stories related to him
please continue sorry to interrupt so so
all these tiger cubs were characters
that were Errol Flynn would have paid
them although no they're all they're all
heroes from from romantic novels watched
buckling normally athletic individuals
that all had big degrees from big
colleges whatever I am my fun was taken
over by one of the tiger cubs and I
think he's one of these individuals they
even if a meteor like that film whatever
was the double impact or Armageddon or
whatever even if it's gonna hit the
earth he will not hedge so we got our
last Friday I got our year-to-date
numbers from the fund and I haven't
really been looking at the fund who must
because I'm just getting on with my own
stuff and I'm not trading it hopefully
we'll be there in ten years time and I
saw he was down 68
percent year-to-date it's honestly so I
thought this is a fund that has now been
going for 23 years and we've managed in
six weeks to lose 68 percent the reason
I say this is because I take my hat off
to the individual involved not for
losing 68 because he would just say
that's a mark-to-market thing he had the
confidence stoicism the belief that when
he was down 68 because I think if I was
down 68 I'd either throw myself in the
river take all bets off I don't think I
would have just done nothing III and I
say that as a criticism of me not a
compliment to me whereas this individual
would turn around and say no it's just
bars and sellers as Marcus in a panic
and of course this week he's he's cut
those losses in half so he's not far
behind the market now I would have been
dreadful in those circumstances have
given it to the right the the right guy
who knows I mean who knows what but I do
think on your TV shows there is a
dispositional bias in the commentary
towards hope and towards blue on the
screen and most thing that's a bad thing
the whole history of your country has
been built on the basis of positivity
and and us Brits could learn a thing or
two about that I just think that if a
market loses a thousand points in the
day and rallies fifty points in the last
10 minutes the headline should not be
diarrhea rallies fifty points in the
last ten minutes it should be dad nine
hundred and fifty on the day it's about
that Titanic story you know but you know
I don't know whether you have it in
America but I'm talking about the UK's
provincial tea and when the Titanic went
down that the headline in my local
newspaper I come from a village in
Scotland called Greenwich and the
headline was Green ik man dies as he
than the Titanic when he was on the
Titanic but I think the the there is a
little bit of a dispositional skew
towards wanting hope and wanting to see
the other side of this and we all share
that but in the short term I'd worry a
little bit
great thank you for thank you for
answering that and we're gonna hop back
into some other subject matter although
people may see some through lines in
maybe the thinking that you bring to
your life and also to this conversation
so I want to go to 2012 and I it would
have been around 2012 I don't know if it
I don't know if it's exactly 2012 but in
that range of 2011 2013 I believe two
things happened that I'd like to talk
about one was the your story of the
Texan attorney nicknamed jaws had
everything around that and then also a
paper that you that you wrote a
discussion paper titled correct me if
I'm wrong the smart way to monetize
strong photography and you can tackle
these in either order but could you
please describe and tell the stories of
these two things sure I think we should
all have heroes and I have two or three
heroes that there's a big gap from those
two or three to the next and actually
the top two are filmmakers Martin
Scorsese's someone I looked up to
enormous Lee but in gold medal position
is is Steven Spielberg and when when
Spielberg shot jaws he was 25 years old
and I was listening to your podcast with
Vinny Vaughn two nights ago and I heard
him mention her emotionally empathetic
he was on onset Tom Hanks obviously
collaborate
with Spielberg an awful lot when when
Tom Hanks was asked what is it that
makes Spielberg the director
cinematographer of our generation Hanks
replied is because he has a fluency in
the language of what it takes to elicit
an emotional reaction I think that's a
very important sentence but I wanna come
on to that later but in 2000 and 2011
our worlds collide a little bit or bit I
wasn't 25 which I think was still jaws
is still I think one of the top 20
grossing films of all time but I got
obsessed with great white sharks and
then the best place in the world to
photograph great whites ah was in false
Bay around the corner from Cape Town is
not now for other for reasons that we
can talk about later maybe if you're if
you're going to try and photograph great
whites not swimming in the water which
is boring because it's been done before
I go back to my car curry analogy of too
many people doing the same thing you I
want a shark coming out of the water I
want to sharp predating on something a
node flew I'd fly down to Cape Town or
from London or Thursday night arrive
Friday morning too late to go on my
vessel and then on Saturday morning
Sunday morning Monday morning I would
spend four hours from 5:00 in the
morning till 9:00 as see in this place
called a tack channel trying to
photograph the great white attacking a
seal coming up predating come flying out
of the water to get us leaching
breaching yep exactly
and I worked with a great marine
biologist who's now a good friend called
Chris fallows he's up and taking the
best to pictures of great whites
breaching that that I know of my friends
back in London were saying you know
David just isn't it cheaper just to go
and see a therapist rather than just for
the Cape Town to say well what an effing
waste of money I mean because every trip
was costing me about
cuz I was still working and every trip
is costing me like about ten thousand
bucks because then I had the boat and
then there had towels and it's their
winter as well so at the height of
everyone in London going and getting
blast in a glass tin barrier watching
Wimbledon tennis or whatever or being on
holiday in abathur Mykonos I would be
shivering my arse off in their winter on
my own trying to photograph a shark
breaching out of the water and I do
think a lot of people worried about my
sanity anyway I wasn't gonna quit you
cannot you cannot quit you you just got
to continue right but equally there are
practical considerations and the season
would run from June until July and on
the the final possible journey out and
no one knows why great whites breach in
the half hour before sunrise and the two
hours after sunrise the the general
supposition is this because the seal
pups cannot see them coming to attack
them and therefore this is their best
time to predate but no one knows the
answer to that anyway on the final day I
get the shot and I remember my heart
beating so quickly and and you you then
got a you've got about a a 40-minute
journey to come into a very modest
little village in near Cape Town called
Simon's town it's actually where the
South African Navy I don't know why
South Africa has a Navy they might need
it first sort of hospital ships in the
next two weeks but I don't know why they
need a navy anyway the Navy is at
Simon's tan and you can never on digital
cameras you can't really find out
whether something is what we call in the
in the trade and I hope my accent
doesn't make a mess of this but out of
whack out of whack means out of focus
either something is in focus
emphatically in focus or it isn't and
there's no ambiguity if it's if it's 2%
out it's 2% out and my sports
photography days taught me that
I I'm very very tough on myself on focus
the oh you're never gonna be able to see
that on the back of your screen on a
camera and a choppy water so I got back
to the cafe and was able to look at it
uh in the cold light of day and it was
in focus the shark attacking the seal
everything was in focus
and I got quite emotional it was a bit
like my story on the plane with Maradona
except I was at sea level not 36,000
feet up and I knew it was a big picture
so I sent it to the agency in London I
was on my own I didn't really have it
was a Sunday morning didn't have anyone
to celebrate with in a beautiful ever
you want to forever you want a great
restaurant in and yours your happen to
be in Cape Town in a place called quark
Bay there's a fish restaurant over the
railway line I think it's called Harbor
lights and and because the the South
African Rand is under a lot of pressure
you can have the best seafood bottle of
wine and he'd get changed for 20 bucks
so I had lunch on my own like the loser
I am with my camera and the picture was
I think in the next week around a
hundred magazines newspapers in the
world all around the world and I got my
check about six months later because
they're all playing you know the game in
terms of delay between them getting the
income in and then being sent here my
check was around about oh no irrelevant
$17,000 and I thought this is got to be
the worst
industry in the world because it must
have cost me at least 25,000 to finally
get that picture yourself I've taken
this picture and I've lost $8,000 from
taking this picture this is I mean I may
as well get back to trying to do
something else I mean what a what a
stupid industry and then I got a call
from someone and I spent a lot of time
in Texas y'all now
the guys that's a bad Texan accident he
said he said are you the kid that took
the photograph of the shark he says
because I'm an attorney I'm called jaws
and I won't want to M picture my wall
because I want to pay the fare of garden
to anyone the little gates against me
and it went from Texas to Forrest Gump
in about ten seconds anyway he he said
how much do you want for the picture now
and this is 11 10 11 years ago and
people weren't looking at photography as
an area where we could for for fine art
and I I said well maybe we'll put in a
nice frame and all maybe there but maybe
charge you ten thousand ten thousand
dollars but he said $10,000 so I
obviously thought I'd gone wait here
wait hi so I said well listen I'm sorry
the thing that's a law I said would
deliver it will deliver it to Texas for
free we might even install it he goes
now I'm gonna have three of them shark
and that was when the penny dropped for
me it was just in that one conversation
that photography at an editorial level
selling pictures to stern magazine or
Perry match or the Sports Illustrated or
the New York Times the London Times
printed picture or one of my pictures
half a page London Times like the New
York Times I don't want anything for it
is it's the best PR you can in the world
so that was when the penny drop that the
way to monetize it if that's not a
vulgar word but the way to make him
living was through fine art and so I
wrote this pieces my ode to Cameron
Crowe in a way because when Jerry
Maguire did it in in in Carey McGowan
when Kristin Italy you remember he wrote
that missus if and then he put it in
everyone's cubby hole and he said the
sports management should look after fear
sport stars and give them more personal
attention
I wrote my mission statement I didn't
did quite as glamorous as Tom Cruise and
it
more than an evening with the tower
around my neck but I did a lot of
homework and the basic essence was that
the future for me in photography was
going to be to not just encroach arts
law a Artie's lawn with my photography
but for it to be an integral part of art
to be something that is quite clearly
art . and that was if you got that right
and from there was gonna be a normal
journey that there was a marketplace and
I look back now yeah it was 120 months
ago probably 120 12 10 years I I think
we with the journeys not ended and the
journeys just having a massive bump for
everyone right now but I've got so many
things wrong in my life but I got it
right and he you write in Europe in your
books which I have read and some of the
podcasts which I've listened to you you
use a word it's very important you use
the word self-propagating and the
importance of self propagation and if
you can get to a position where your
brand is recognized and strong so many
good things come from that inner in a
way that you don't actually have to as
long as you look after the brand the
position can reinforce itself when we've
restoring selling pictures for $5,000
$5,000 seems an awful lot for a
photograph I I look back in and we had
one subject we haven't talked about when
I did a sports when I did supports
photography my claim to fame was a John
McEnroe spat on me a Wimbledon Eagle 15
point code violation for many years that
was my that was my biggest claim to fame
but I used to sell pictures outside the
tube station underground storage and
their depth in that subway metro yeah
for 20 bucks
way back in way back in the day in 1987
of it was the great days when you had
America had fantastic tennis players
nothing you don't know me of an amazing
women's tennis players and Coco's quite
something but in the days of on the
men's side you had macaroon Connors and
Gerulaitis it was just like what big
party but you just want a good party
with those guys but but I would sell
pictures for 20 bucks so in art Miami
last year I did say to people we sold a
picture for $200,000 and someone said
well that's an awful lot David that's
quite I said well how I could be accused
of taking my time because that was 35
years after I was selling pictures for
20 quid outside a subway station in
Dublin
I think there are a lot of lessons to be
to be learned from that let's look a
little more closely at that discussion
paper the smart way to monetize stronger
photography so my understanding is that
it included an analysis of the business
models or approaches of - at least - I'm
not sure if there are more very
successful photographers at the time
could you speak to what observations or
conclusions you made of those successful
photographers yeah absolutely and then
the first thing I'd say about
photography and almost more than
anything else that I will say in this
interview is you Tim I so believe in
this from the bottom of my heart that
photography is collegiate I don't
compete against other photographers this
is not a zero-sum game job I think
you've used that expression just because
you're doing well it doesn't mean
someone else should do badly and
vice-versa brain I also I remember that
in the World Cup semi-final I did the
first ten minutes of West Germany
against there are still cold West
Germany West German against France and
my camera broke ten minutes into the
World Cup semi-final and the Italian
photographer next to me he could see us
having problems and he said my friends
he said except he said it in Italian
here is my camera he just gave me his
camera and he had no right to do that
and that's what photography I think is
like that the two photographers that I
mentioned in that piece were both live I
think in America one's Australian ones
actually British the first one is a guy
called Nick Brandt and Nick first got
involved in photography as a
cinematographer I think he was doing the
filming of a Michael Jackson video that
happened to be shot in the Serengeti in
Tanzania that was a cold earth song I
can't remember the Michael Jackson I
think it might have been called that and
he fell in love with the plains of
Serengeti he was a creative guy and he
decided to spend more and more time in
East Africa filming and he focused on
part of all the big elephants in the
world are in Kenya if you want to go and
photograph a big elephant and I'm very
much I'm a romanticist but I'm also a
magnifier as well so if I want to go and
photograph an Abba tribute band I'll do
it in Stockholm I will go to where it's
at so with elephants the best place to
photograph elephant big elephants in the
world is Kenya there are about 20 to
what are called big Tusker elephants
left in the world they're there they the
elephants that look half like an
elephant and half like a mammoth from
Ice Age with the tusks touch the ground
and they're only in two national parks
they're in a national park or Amboseli
and a national park called Tsavo where
Peter Beard who I'm sure you know Peter
beers work he's from the Andy Warhol
school and a great storyteller
photographer he's
a lot of time in Sava Nick spent a lot
of time in this place called amber celli
and he photographed him black and white
and I always have photographs tended to
photographing black and white we can
maybe come onto that later and his work
was shot on film not digital but he was
achieving very high prices for his work
and I admired it and I still do he got
there before me we don't know each other
but I have total respect for him and I
know printers that he's used to use have
known a lot of galleries who knows know
us both and he gives an awful lot back
to conservation and he is not someone
that likes socializing and I respect
that as well which is why you need to
use the wholesale marketplace for other
people to extol the virtues of your work
we have an acronym in the UK which I'm
sure Tim you have an American are called
fig jam
GFG I don't know isn't what that means
so fig jam means in Britain [ __ ] I'm
good just asked me also explain what you
mean by using the wholesale market so by
deep rooted calling both of those so
wholesale means using galleries because
you if you're a photographer and you
want to sell your your work you've got
really two options in the fine art
market number one is you can go to the
best galleries in the world that one
week might be selling Picasso's or
Warhol's or baskets or whatever and say
or or or photographic galleries and he
say here's here's my work and they'll
take 50% they will take 50% of the sale
that's standard and Nick embraced that a
model to the full and to the party
because he didn't
to go and be selling it yourself around
the world it's a lot of work and you
could get the content it's not like
original content providers like Netflix
she's not got the guy that's making the
latest episode of the crown the next
week shrugging around Berlin trying to
flog it but you know he's not gonna have
much of a home life if that's the basis
but if you need wholesalers to destroy
our biggest market in the world outside
London is in Dallas no I went to Dallas
seven hours ago and by your market you
mean our biggest market you mean you
personally or do you mean fine art
photography no for me personally so
seven years ago I didn't know anyone in
Dallas but in order to get to that
position you need a gallery and then you
just build up contacts and we are Dallas
I go to Dallas now more than they go to
New York or LA and even culminated I
couldn't cut my family and friends
certainly can I even had the pleasure of
having lunch at SMU with George W and
that was that was a great thrill and
that all just came from Texan
hospitality and just getting to know
people but with the gallery with the
gallery at the epicenter of that with
the gallery to talk about me so why cuz
I just yeah let's let's I know we're
gonna get to fig jam but why on earth
Dallas I know Texas actually has a lot
of art but you could also say that of
Los Angeles you say that of New York you
could say that of Chicago how did Dallas
come to be your number two I think Texas
is you know there is a it's a great
sense of hospitality there people people
want to help I might be losing here with
rose-tinted spectacles Babar Nagy we've
been welcomed with open arms
there is irrespective of when the oil
price is twenty four bucks a barrel or
seventy bucks a barrel I think that
intense correlation between Texan wealth
and all price has loosened a little bit
and I'm sure life in Houston isn't quite
as good right now with the old prices it
was what
60 or 70 but I think there's enough
money there that it doesn't matter so
much you then get into this
extraordinary contradiction between
conservationists and hunters you go back
in the history of America so many of
your great man were hunters and
conservationists Roosevelt SR you know
in Texas there are an awful lot of these
like safari clubs and whatever the
hunters and then they go into Safari to
Africa so and I'm a conservationist I
don't really want to get aggressively
into the debate as to whether you should
spend your weekend shooting ducks but I
certainly am someone that can't really
be seen to be shooting duck so that
weekend I think that would open the
doors to a degree of double standards
but there are big walls big homes the
areas like the Highland Park's of this
world there's a great clan base there
and we've got to know we shot recently
with the Dallas Cowboys and which is
great fun and Troy Aikman actually came
along to the ship we closed down the
city center of Dallas and I thought what
are we gonna do what are we gonna put in
the city center of Dallas and I thought
well we're gonna have the cheerleaders
and then we get a bunch of longhorn
cattle and some cowboys and and we did
it we closed down the center and we got
we got some cattle some cowboys and
sentir leaders and just let's see what
let's see what happens see I wanna like
that but how did it start did it come
from you reaching out to someone did it
come from an agency who represents you
reaching out to someone did it start
with a cold email from some you know big
hat plus cattle money family in Dallas
how did it start which becomes they did
Dallas itself for the idea so wearing my
old hat I'm the geek a school that knows
all the detail on the baseball cards but
if you substitute baseball cards for
American cities I think I don't think I
don't think I do too badly telling you
you you name an American city will tell
what they are markets like in in in
growth ii cities Nashville Charlotte
Austin the Carolinas
how strong are these markets where were
the big markets and there are some tough
markets in America that I think the two
toughest markets that people assume are
slam dunks are bizarre let's forget
about what everything that's going on at
the moment but Los Angeles is a tough
market and New York is a tough market
Los Angeles is a tough market because
the wealth lives in tends to live in two
different places either on the beach or
in the hills or around West Hollywood
and the best of my knowledge there one
are apart so Ari
lacay see a gallery you immediately
eliminate half of them also people in LA
but like San Fran and you have
experience of this their invitation rich
particularly in in LA their their time
poor their friendship rich and they they
really don't want to go to things it's
not a treat to go to an art gallery
opening
they just think they'd rather avoid it
they'd rather what take the dog to the
vet then get an art gallery and this is
one or the therapist
whereas eager oh and in New York is
simmering away and that my work is quite
large and Peter Beard had a similar
issue you and if you got it in in in New
York you can go to that kind of waspy
Upper East Side but the galleries are
small they're by definition because the
rents are so high and if you've got a
gallery in Upper East Side they could
probably only fit three or four my
pictures in there then you go down to
Soho and West Broadway where we've been
before and the rents in some of those
places are enormous and maybe the
galleries are more kind of pop art
galleries than galleries with the
provenance of some of the ones in in
Upper East Side so you are to lead
cities in a wafer and I don't think I'd
be the only person to say this to her
present challenges
whereas Dallas and Chicago are
fantastic they're not quite as
invitation rich with the greatest
respect my friends in both Chicago and
Dallas there their site may be slightly
more genuine friendships maybe have more
substance they want to introduce you to
more people and the gallery competition
maybe isn't quite as stiff and both
economies present circumstances excluded
are strong so are there's a big gap for
us between Dallas Chicago and the next
market we have in the state and so it
was this was a research driven decision
on your part to target Dallas and
Chicago as prep primary primary cities
is that right yeah I mean I think that's
right and I think the kind of founding
father of photography in the States
lives in Palm Beach and the gallery is
on that Worth Avenue yet with all the
smart golf clubs and the luxury goods
stores and whatever and he turned me
down five times and there's nothing you
you write an awful lot about in in your
work about what you take out of
rejection and not quite hitting it and
everyone has different responses to and
I mean I'm a great believer that you
have to experience those times to get
better and if you're a British guy and
you turn up at the most important art
gatekeeper for contemporary photography
in America and he looks at you and he
says thank you but no thank you
and then you have to roll your portfolio
up and then get a taxi or whatever to
Miami International and then get a
flight back to London that's that's a
lot of time to do a little bit of
self-loathing or also or say well sooner
or later he
not gonna tear me down and just going
off on a tangent here but probably my
worst time you know our Scottish writer
that the JK Rowling of Harry Potter Fame
and her lovely expression of his rock
bottom was the solid foundation which
had built my life and but my right my my
rock bottom was probably in 2012 so
after I'd written my Jerry Maguire piece
but no one really wanted to listen too
much and the guy in Palm Beach had
turned me down four or five times and he
represented Nick actually he represented
Nick Branton and Nick and justifiably so
and there was a Christmas in 2012 where
I'm sure some many of your viewers will
resonate with them unfortunately that
sometimes when a marriage doesn't work
there'll be one day in a year if you
have children that it can be tricky and
Christmas taken can sometimes be that
day in terms of whether you're gonna see
your children or not and my ex-wife and
I now have a wonderful relationship and
she's here cohabiting with me in our
house with the family now
but this those eight years ago things
weren't so good and so it was very clear
to me that I wasn't gonna see my kids on
Christmas Day and there's two ways she
can react it I felt that you could be
round the corner with her with friends
watching Love Actually for the 20th time
feeling miserable and pretending to keep
a brave smile on being a loser or you
can get the [ __ ] out of there
so I decided on the latter and I felt it
kind of calling in a way that I needed
to go and do something and and South
Sudan was going through a civil war I
had seen some imagery there and I'm kind
of led quite a bit by the imagery of
others without wanting to plagiarize it
and it looked like there was there was
stuff there that if I could just get far
enough North and South Sudan I could get
a picture that could
the test of time if I got my lighting
right in my logistics right and I got it
I saw on Christmas Day I spent Christmas
Day at a United Nations refugee camp in
in in South Sudan with a lot of guns
knocking around and just drove north
with my minders in in tough areas
whether it's civil war was going on and
I on the 27th of December - my people
watching after you apperance yeah guys
with guns I think you know that my my
food I think cost me about a dollar a
day and the accommodation was about a
dollar a day and then security details
about a thousand a day anyway honor
honor we go I got the picture and it had
a I think the best pictures can be
looked at for a long time and this
picture could be looked at for a long
time I felt so I left South Sudan on
about the 28th of December I get all my
printing done in Los Angeles and so
eventually found my way from East Africa
to LA got the picture printed and then
took it to the gatekeeper in Palm Beach
and this is the same person that had
rejected me for five times five times
and he looked at it and he said he said
how old are you which I thought he
should probably have known by now babe
Washington so I lied as we all do these
days and I probably pretended I was
younger than what I was how my mother
said another 42 or I don't know 43 he
said he said this picture is gonna
change the second half of your life and
I said I said well hopefully for the
better because the last 10 years haven't
been up so much and he said no it's
gonna change for the better I I said
why's that
he said because it's a picture people
need to see and he's gonna represent you
from tomorrow and that was why I was the
that was the moment and I remember again
getting absolutely drunk hammered pissed
whatever the British expression American
expression is back in Miami and again on
my own
and that was the kind of that was the
moment and the Palm Beaches is it is a
very important market albeit is it
season as you know it kind of starts in
November and then goes through the may
you know the extraordinary thing about
your country is the geographical
mobility of people that have done well
they will they will they will have homes
sure that might have a home in the
plains of where they work but one of so
many people from Palm Beach you find in
Aspen at times or up in Nantucket or
whatever in your holiday destinations
there there does seem to be quite a
little expression you could be careful
with right now but cross-fertilization
there does seem to me people do hop and
scotch and your your resort markets we
are we are we've had no we have no doubt
in our mind that if you take all top 20
ski resorts in the world
in terms of the what you can learn the
quality the people that are there and I
know you're gonna get many people that
disagree with this to an extent the
wealth the connections and in Europe you
have five or six big ones where we'd
have shows but Aspen for all its things
that I don't necessarily embrace it
takes a lot of Billy as as a resort to
other get to be shown in and we had a
show in Christmas this year it's quite
funny actually because they the gallery
said we will give you a discount on your
hotel because obviously you're gonna
have to come to your family and I before
I I asked what the discount was from I
said that's very kind if you will all be
there and then when you get to ask for a
new year you get a room about the size
of I don't know a shoebox and they ask
you for like 800 bucks for it your
discount standing 720 but it's still you
do meet some fascinating people there
and and that's that's another great
place to to share at America two quick
questions is is Palm Beach an important
market for as a
for revenue in other words a percentage
of let's say income or is it important
symbolically because the tastemakers
their influence representation and
purchase decisions and so on elsewhere
or both your very good Tim knows that
you're very give us that's the right
question and announce the answer is a
bit of both
there are galleries that we show at that
might not ring the bell in sales all the
time but the fact that they are part of
your dream team and that they rep you
serves two purposes direct sales and
also the provenance that someone that is
seen to be a scholar in the art of this
election of artists has for whatever
reason deemed to include you in their
squad so in New Orleans has
extraordinary places now I I love it I
don't know it that well I was there
three weeks ago and the the art district
it's clearly being done up quite a lot
known and developing quickly and we work
with I think one of the most celebrated
galleries in in Southern America people
call Arthur Roger and he's been a big
donator to Nomar the earliest Museum of
Modern Art Arthur will not necessarily
be selling at the levels that galleries
in London or or Dallas or Chicago but he
is so loved and so respected that the
fact that you're part of his stable only
curries favor elsewhere
I guess you're you're allowed isn't it a
bit like some of the actors that you
interview they will do stage
performances they will go on Broadway
from time to time in my Dorner and the
big bucks but it's good for their spirit
and good for their soul and not every
gallery we work at we've got 25 around
the world and not everyone they should
not be clones of each other and some are
a higher ticket galleries
that have less charm and then some are
galleries you just love spending time
with and asking questions and tapping
into their extraordinary life and and
and knowledge and Palm Beach is a bit
like that
and an Orleans is a bit like that but
the Palm Beach II do see the incredible
mobility of I used to go to the the
Masters in Augusta quite a bit and I
know it's a smart event but when you
just as an outsider when you listen to
the conversations that are going around
under that oak tree by the clubhouse
it shows the extraordinary geographical
mobility of your nation you'll meet
people for say where are you now I'm
living in Seattle last time I was living
in in Chicago and then before oh you've
moved you've moved up from from Austin
or whatever those conversations don't
happen in most countries in the world
they just happen in your country and
that means that if you've got a if
you've got galleries in 11 or 12 of the
hotspots you do get that great
cross-fertilization yeah that's very
very true and I promised I had a second
question in fact I have many questions
including the second I had in mind was
getting back to fig jam
there's your obsession with the Netflix
business model in Montana
there's making versus taking photographs
all sorts but would you mind if we take
a brief bathroom break since I've been
mainlining green tea for this entire
conversation well done let's do fun
let's do five minutes and we'll be right
back
we are back from respective bathroom
breaks ready to go and made a few
promises before my bladder was on the
verge of exploding fig jam
Netflix business model Montana we may
not cover it all because we have some
time limitations today but let's let's
jump into fig jam
what was the thread on fig jam so the
other photographer though though I
talked about in my piece my mission
statement was a photographer Australian
photographer Col Peter lake Peter
decided he's a good for a very strong
smart photographer hard-working
photographer but he decided to
vertically integrate the food chain but
what I mean by that is that he would
take the pictures but it would be his
galleries that would sell his own
pictures and that that is it's not a
unique business model there quite a few
American photographers in the Rockies if
you get a place like Jackson Hole or
even Aspen you'll see guys that take the
pictures and then they have the
galleries selling their own pictures
obviously their margins are way higher
because they're not splitting the take
with a gallery because they are the
gallery the problem is is there is fake
jam it is [ __ ] good just ask me there
is nothing better than third-party
affirmation if you're asking your best
mate about a potential new girlfriend
and your best mate or vice versa the
best mate says I think I think she's
excellent I think she's perfect that
means so much more to you if your
girlfriend's ask his girlfriend about a
potential guy and since the same we look
for third-party affirmation I don't like
to talk about my work too much other
than when it's my job when I'm on show
when I'm on a stage or whatever or
something like this you need their party
to do it a lot of people turn around and
say you know what the last unregulated
market in the world is the art market I
don't believe that's true I think is one
of the most regulated markets because
it's self policed and something that is
self pleased that regulation can
actually be much more onerous than
something that is regulated by law and
if you do something that is seen to be
out with what is perceived to be right
by the art market you've got to be
careful and I used Peter as an example
in because no one has succeeded more in
the first cointegration
of their business and Peter but he
ruffled quite a few feathers by doing it
because if he turns around and says he
sold a picture for a million dollars
well how do we actually know the
provenance of that I'm not suggesting
that the New York Times did it's a tough
market to own the stores to sell your
own work war hold and basket and it is a
counterpoint to where you ended up going
was it a cautionary tale more than a
best practices yeah you know I am I
thought Breaking Bad you weren't
expecting I was gonna go from there to
break let's talk about this let's go
there let's just go straight in -
there's so many of those meth fans on
the way that the Mexican border by the
way from Marfa everyone looks like that
one that they used in breaking about
anyway putting that to one side breaking
breaking bad to me was should be not
only in every cinematography class
manual but it should be on every
economics class manual so the
cinematography side I think it was in
emphatically the series that showed the
power of immersive filmmaking we live in
an era of wanting to be there my
photography I hope is immersive because
I use wide-angle lenses rather than
largely telephoto lenses so you feel
you're part of there rather than
compressing distance if you can press
distance a compresses emotion if I'm
gonna photograph a man or a woman I'm
not gonna photograph them from a hundred
yards away I'm gonna photograph them
from a foot and a half away with a
wide-angle lens and breaking bad did
that it also should be in economics
robux because from the moment that he
went from supplying the crystal-meth
himself to a wholesale business model
the career in the series took off it was
just that was the tipping point just go
wholesale baby and that's when he saw
the power of being able to just have
sales everywhere don't worry about the
margin so much but if you go sales
coming out of your arse in every big
city in the world then or in his case
every big city in New Mexico court hasta
New Mexico it's gonna make a difference
and so Breaking Bad it was instructive
for me to me for two different reasons
so that means that you you looked at the
from removing the name correctly Peter
lik yes L okay as an example of
commercial success but one wrought with
difficulties and risks that ended up
being a cautionary tale of sorts that
steered you towards wholesale while
embracing some of the best practices
from the other gentlemen who you I don't
know if his job but the other man
you're so articulate and he summarized
that brilliantly well yes that's that's
right Peter Peter you want to have
here's a brand and he has constancy in
his product in this product quality we I
have a few expressions on our business
one is Tom Ford Tom Ford Tom Ford when
we go Tom Ford Tom Ford Tom Ford what do
we mean everything has to be constant in
in the commitment to the pursuit of
excellence in and taste and so the
people when they're looking at the frame
of our picture they'll go that's a David
era frame they were
even if the photograph wasn't there even
if the photograph was the poster for
once upon a time in Hollywood they go
yeah I know that film that's a David
Yarra frame the second thing I I stoop
and I still do stay close to the
creative director and Victoria's Secrets
now Victoria Secrets has had a stunning
fall from grace over the last 18 months
but and we don't have the time to go
into the wherewithal and the reasons for
that and whether they're right reasons
or not but clearly the brand is not of
the our it is not what people want in
2020 and I and I understand that when
Victoria's Secret their head office was
in Columbus Ohio and when you used to go
into their head office in the foyer they
had two things they had the newspaper
from 21st of November 1963 with the
headline candidly dead and then they had
another saying that said perhaps you
should be tougher on yourself I think we
should be tougher on ourselves I think
you you you and your writings to him and
I've seen quite a bit you use the
example of an athlete that has the
expression no one owes us anything and I
think that's the kind of corollary of
perhaps you should be tougher on
yourself I think the world of there's no
reason for anyone to go by David Yarra
work tomorrow unless is constantly the
best that I can do and it's given third
party advocacy it's not for me to tell
them to buy it is for someone else to
tell them and I had mark Peter for
trying to circumvent that I think he's
the only person that's succeeded it just
wouldn't be for me I wouldn't like to
have 25 retail stores right now in
America of my own yes I would agree with
that conclusion for for these these
times right now
in particular where where does your
fascination with Netflix and Montana I'm
not saying those two are related
come come into the picture so to speak I
know that that's that's probably a
little little too on the nose
no but but we're yeah could you speak to
either of those because Netflix is a
fascinating business model if finally
dawned on the commentators on television
today to say because they were trying to
find businesses that were immune from
the crisis that we're currently staring
in the face of and you hear this word
Netflix coming up time and time again
and I'm wanting to kick the TV in
because I'm sitting at home unable to
film unable to travel and I'm going
Netflix can't produce any new content of
course they're exposed to this what do
you mean that they're immune to
coronavirus they're right on the heart
of it where's the new content they are
original content it's in their mission
statement they fascinate me because
they're cook their courage and
investment the crown take through the
series of crown and for all the
Americans please don't believe
everything that's in there I know people
say I I watch it because it's
educational half is [ __ ] but it's
good fun nevertheless anyway so it's
like 10 million an episode or throw in a
couple for post-production marketing 12
million so you do a series of eight so
you're kind of talking about a hundred
more in a series their accounting
fascinates me because they were amortize
that cost over the expected worth of the
crown no I'm far be it from me to
criticize the accounting of Netflix but
if we spent as we did last week 250
grand in Texas we'll take that through
the P&L last week I'm not gonna spread
that over eight years but what they have
taught us is the importance of investing
with confidence and the mistakes that
we've made my goodness we make a lot
is when we decide should we go for
option a of a replica 1850s wagon that
was made actually in 1970 by Ford or do
we go for an original 1850s wagon that's
gonna cost double the amount of the
replicas if you take that forth if you
take the six thousand saving it's a
false economy in our own little modest
way so we have to have courage in our
investment and Netflix and it's still
saris I think you have America has the
most visually spoiled country in the
world of that there is for me over
everything that I've said that some
people might find contentious or being
even be interested in I think you have
by far and away the the most
extraordinary canvas on which to tell
stories of any country in the world
because you have such diversity whether
it be the urban beauty of Chicago the
swamps of Louisiana the John Ford
scenery of Arizona and then the Rockies
of Wyoming and Montana and for a artist
I wish I hope that's what I am it is a
dream and of all of all the states the
one that I get most excited of coming
back to is probably Montana because I
think it's still the least dense I don't
know if they got a coronavirus I don't
know how I wonder what the numbers are
but they're gonna be single-digit I
think everything everyone lives remotely
in the mountains there anyway when I
arrived there and you get the Big Sky
feel and you think this is amazing but
then you meet the people that are there
and some of them that live up in the
mountains it's just the the people that
time forgot there is a coordinate kind
of Time Warp and high up some of the
better voles has some sort of visceral
attraction to ghost towns maybe it's a
maybe it's a manifestation of my my
childhood fears of a
it's not manifesting yourself in in a
love of ghosts ads it happened to you
too so that we stumbled across this
ghost town right up in the hills and of
course because their hide had been
preserved better than the ghost hands
maybe in in in California in Arizona and
it's the characters there that we meet
and we met this guy I was so cold of
filming outside and I just wanted to get
a drink at the end of the day and I
walked into this bar that should have
been looked like it had been closed in
the ghost town and there was a guy
behind the bar that looked like he
killed about 10 people on it and it was
open and and it was your quintessential
American saloon bar with the the wagon
wheel on the top and the long bar going
back and back and back and they killer
dick because the stuffed moose head and
all that kind of stuff and I thought
this is gonna be a great place for a
shoot
I want to we talked we talked about
making pictures and taking pictures and
I do tend to have preconceptions but you
are allowed to have spontaneity and I
said well can we bring a wolf in here
and he said we have we'll see or Monday
Wednesday Thursday is fine wolves come
in here the whole time and nothing was
too much trouble for him and I put some
chicken wings around my on a string
around my head around my chest and lay
on the bar and then the wolf would walk
along the bar to try and bite the
chicken off my that is the hell of a
hell of a sentence right there the great
thing is so we got the picture and every
Friday night now people try and
replicate the wolf on the bar so the
only tongue my life I've something I've
done has given rise to a bar game in the
evening so you got to try and reenact we
took Cindy Crawford up to that bar and
she was great sport and she played she
played along with the wolf and these
guys who the piss
it's a debris use this waste
[ __ ] yeah pista means upset but yeah
[ __ ] fest and he's this guy he's at the
bar and one of my rules is whenever we
shoot in a bar in the mountains it's an
open bar all day so throughout the day
apps that other than me hopefully gets
hammered and this guy when Cindy's won
sighs you've got an American sweetheart
a Nikon and though she is looking
graceful splendid and then on the
right-hand side he got a Manson guy 885
and he's so excited to be standing next
to Cindy Crawford he actually pisses in
his pants and you can see the wet so if
you don't believe me it's in the picture
but we we have a love affair we went to
this place called Butte Montana and it
was it was a big old copper mining place
in the old days and it was abandoned in
about 1950 but a lot of it as it was
left and we shot there in January and
the cold and there's in the it was in
its heyday when Prohibition came in and
with it kind of speakeasies and stuff
like that and we found a few of these
speakeasies and it was such a wonderful
canvas on which to tell painting tell
stories whenever I talk about your world
West I I get energized because to me
that final frontier expansion and the
stories of goodbye good guys bad guys
outlaws endeavor drunkenness whatever
crime is one of the great periods of
history and there's a romanticist within
me that just loves that pushing to the
final frontier
I can't articulate it but what a great
story in which to tell what a great
canvas and wish to tell pictures and so
where we've been we've been attacking
Wyoming on Montana and then the next
move seemed to go to Texas because it's
the home of the real cowboys and some
but we we are we're we show there two
weeks ago and right down I think you
know the area well given where you live
now
but we were shooting on the Rio Grande
in a big band National Park which is one
of the I think the least visited but
most beautiful American parks the only
people that live there are kind of in
witness protection program otherwise or
the crystal-meth operators otherwise he
wouldn't be there or the Mexican but
they you you could take we cross to the
Mexican border
four times in the morning because all
you have to do is cross a 25-yard stream
and we were we were working with some
gameofthrones
people which is great fun and you just
said well we're Mexico in two minutes
and with photograph herself in Mexico
and then we would go back and forth and
we had some proper Cowboys down there
and to me those are my most exciting
days to be to be doing that in your
country which is there's so much history
but recent history at the year at your
19th century history is more exciting
than Europeans 19th century history has
to be so I have one one more question
we'll have to do around to because I
want to ask you about Scorsese oh and
ask you about your near-death
experiences I want ask you about all
sorts of things so what we'll have to do
if you're up for it around to at some
point yes please
but you have and this is this is a whole
area that we could talk about really
honed the craft of not just photography
but collaboration with different people
and different groups your view I think
you've been very smart very methodical
it would see him in how you've
approached that so you mentioned Cindy
Crawford of course you've you've done a
lot with many many household names how
did you get your first celebrity
collaboration and you can interpret or
define celebrity however you like it but
how did you get the first one
or whatever early day story comes to
mind it the the first the first point
I'd make is that I'm not I'm not drawn
to celebrity per se I in my younger life
I dated someone that was much more
famous than I'll ever be by multiple of
100 and the whole concept of being
famous like that wastin scares me this
is slightly some some people say when
you meet some of these individuals
you must does your ego go up and
actually it's presses any kind of ego
Huff because they're just so our
standings as individuals and and you're
humbled by their normality but
appreciative excellence by their family
values by their manners that's important
manners by their self deprecation I
remember remember going in your writings
you talk about when you were a lecturer
at Princeton and I've talked to
Princeton several times because my
daughter wants to get in because you
know let's bug him any money these days
the ethical way to do is to give a few
free species and I mean it didn't work
species were fine but she just stayed in
the UK but you talk about you gave your
your class a test of making an
uncomfortable phone call or email to
someone to turn have a conversation or
meeting or a message from someone very
high part whether it be the chairman of
Google whoever it was I I'm quite sure I
had those things but I've got better at
it and I would also encourage people to
say that we've all been rejected in our
life there's no shame in rejection
rejection is part and parcel the game I
think you you can may be being rejected
10 times in one day can may be a little
bit too much for someone but
you can you can stagger your rejection
rate but never be afraid to do it the
one thing that I know from every person
that people put on a pedestal as to how
extraordinary and their celebrity status
is that they're all like us as Bill
Gates said yesterday in his 15 things
we've learned about coronavirus ego and
fame as they don't differentiate we're
all the same and everyone that I've met
this as celebrity in some eyes the fast
majority of our 90% of the time just
like us
sport stars I found a very nervous about
art in the same way if you took an
artist to a man corner of the Augusta
Masters he would be nervous to ask where
the par-3 was in the pair of bar fives
were and you know how does the 13th play
or whatever in the very same way sports
stars that I met are nervous about art
and therefore if you can
I think people by people I don't think
that people necessarily buy products
when the product is the work of a single
person
they must rather tell the story about
the person 95% of our art is being
bought by people that have met me one
way or other listen to me - miss speak
which you can argue makes it a
non-expandable business model and as a
work hard but I think by and large you
got with with celebs if you can you know
celebrities or people that have been I
hate the word actually celebrity people
there have been champions of their
industry if you can find a way to engage
them I with someone as to go right to
the top right to the top and the the
glue if you like the glue this
suck it all together is fundraising for
charity
I've been lucky that my work is valued
and because when we produces print
there'll be 16 in a series 16 to 2/3 of
those to go to good causes doesn't cost
me anything it marginally cannibalizes
the addition but so what that's
fantastic and through that that's forged
many links and so for something like
with with with Cindy she she lost her
brother to leukemia at a very young age
she would work with me for nothing as
long as a good percentage of the
proceeds went to the hospital in Madison
Wisconsin that looks after her her
brother so that's now equated to half a
million dollars
that's much more exciting for her than
her getting a check of 40 grand for a
boring furnish it she doesn't want that
she's done enough of those she's earned
the right not to have to do that and she
is a champion for those kind of things
so the more advocates we have like that
the better their odds Tim you know you
interview a lot of them there I think
they are so long of kindness most of the
time I don't know about you and and this
is a rhetorical comment when you're
dealing with these people
it's the entourage that I can't deal
with when you actually meet I mean it's
a bit like it's been like you Nate your
entourage I mean but you seem quite a
decent guys that people underneath you
my team's great you know that I I don't
have an entourage I think it's the big
bald head that scares them off but but
yeah in my experience Fame is like if
we're talking about Fame I mean which
often accompanies accomplishment in
different fields it's it's a nonspecific
amplifier just like alcohol in the sense
that if you're a small-time [ __ ]
you're going to become a big-time
[ __ ] and if your kind of heart and
jovial and
compliment people then you're going to
become probably a magnified or
exaggerated form of that so I think it
just it it amplifies the best and worst
of people so the folks that I've spent
time with whether that's the Edward
Norton's or the Jamie Foxx's wherever
they're they're great
I really think everyone's a big
conservationist he's huge yeah and and
and then on the flip side those who
shall remain nameless I've met some very
very well-known a listers who are just
[ __ ] awful and I think that you end
up finding people on opposite ends of
the spectrum when you get up to that
level of visibility and there's there's
I haven't run into much in the middle
either and I've heard you what you're
saying about Cindy from friends of mine
who know her I've never met her that
she's just one of the sweetest most
kind-hearted easy to work with people
they've ever met and I've heard that
about Jennifer Garner as well and we had
a we had a moment with Cindy where in
order to get a wolf's attention you can
either make it an aggressive movement
one where they're bit like a dog or you
can make an aggressive noise but wolves
like dogs are smart so they get bored of
that after whilst here your third option
is to use meat and we're shooting
outside it's minus 15 and I've got the
wolf in the car next is Cindy and I'm
just trying to get the wolf to look me
in the eyes and to get the attention
we're using meat and the wolf Wrangler
has this chicken drumstick that has been
in icy water and it's about minus 12 and
he's gonna glove on and to my horror he
loses his throw of it and the drumstick
from ten yards wax industry on the in
the eye on the face cold chicken broth
drumstick f9 Laurent and because she
doesn't know him the only person that
really has
ability without responsibility is is me
and I'll never forget it she just looked
me straight in the eye and went David
and it was the gap after David it was
David that was inappropriate and the gap
between David and that were that was was
probably only two seconds but it felt
like about an hour to me he was finds
his brain and that hospital you go up to
I've never been I'm digressing on I know
we're short of time but I went to
there's a football team in Wisconsin
Madison called the Badgers and when when
when the Madison banner Wisconsin
Badgers or whatever in the UK our
college sport is watched by six people
so we go to this this place in Wisconsin
there's like seventy five thousand
people in the stadium and for us British
people it's just a huge eye-opener to
your college system and how fantastic it
is and I love the fact that in your
college games people turn up in the UK
people leave sports games at halftime
because your team's losing in America
people arrive at halftime so they can be
drunk because they're not allowed to
drink in the stadium so it's the only
place in the world where I've seen and
I've probably been to more football
sports teams and most of the world you
your college games this is the only
place I know where they fill up a
half-time rather than people leave at
halftime and the people that arrive are
all drunk it's fantastic David I think
it's probably a good point to put a
bookmark in conversation number one on
the podcast I think it would be fun to
have another if you're up for it at some
point we certainly have lots and lots
and lots of ground that we could cover
topics to explore and so on but is there
anything that you would like to say
before we close and where can people
best find you and your work learn more
about you on the Internet
my website is david yaris photography we
show in galleries in in America and in
Europe and a little bit in the in the
forest
but additive an on Instagram we've got a
reason presence on on Instagram I am
Mike my favorite story is a metaphor to
to my career is that the one that you'll
know world of Thomas Edison when he's
trying to create permanent light and Eve
fails for the umpteenth time yet another
time and they were press conference and
one of the young journalists at the
front says mr. Edison you seem to have
failed again to create permanent lights
you've been trying this for five years
and it feels like we've made no progress
at all
and Edison replies on the contrary young
man I've learned 100 ways how not to
create permanent light and there is an
element in terms in in in my work with
all animals in the by learning how to
get it wrong we've learned how to get a
right I mean with the pictures we've
managed to take with mountain gorillas
in Rwanda with with Lions in Africa with
polar bears in Alaska or Norway with
orangutangs with the biggest elephants
in the world it is by an iterative
relationship between taking a picture
recognizing its inherent weaknesses and
the areas where we can quite plausibly
improve that you get towards the kind of
work you're looking for I don't think
that process is any different from what
you do or what 99% of people do is how
determined you are that to fulfill that
virtuous circle upwards of just saying
no we need to get better at that bit or
this bit or whatever and and there's
some times people say the easiest
question I get asked him is well you
know what's your best picture and of
course the answer is it hasn't been
taken yet because if you if you feel
that it was taken in 2013
how dispersing those seven or eight
years ago you to your greatest picture I
would hope that when all this dreadful
forest and repercussions for people
which we've been blessed the
uneffected comes to us to neumann that
I'll go out and I'll take far better
pictures never say before what's the
point of believing anything else gotta
gotta gotta believe that your best works
out of you this this podcast will be a
blip in your bottom left to top right
perfect linear upward trajectory of your
podcast well you know I wouldn't I feel
strange saying I hope this is a blip but
I certainly hope that my best work is
ahead of me I agree with you that
there's there's a strong case for
optimism because what other choice do
you have
in a lot of respects it doesn't mean
you're not practical it doesn't mean you
don't learn from your mistakes but
especially in times like these if you
don't have some glimmer of hope I think
you don't just lose your morale but you
also lose your ability to to plan in in
many cases if there isn't a future worth
looking forward to that you can imagine
so this is a wonderful line in talking
about Tom Hanks films bridge of spies
and you remember Mark Rylands who pays
the the spy in Russia and when he's
imprisoned one of the Russians bar in
America and and when Tom Hanks
interviews him in the cell for the first
time Tom Hanks says do you understand
the severity of the circumstances that
are currently upon you and he replies
what if I did would it make me feel any
better and I think that's quite a person
for this time that you have to you have
to be an optimist you have to look you
have to believe in the world improving
at some stage and if we were to examine
a ting of just how miserable this is
right now for from every facet of
society in business and finance it's
gonna make for a fairly miserable
evening so one would hope that you just
got to look over over the hill
bridge of spies is a great movie and
seeing if we dig into it a little bit
more because it is all it is one of my
favorite scenes he asks him if he
understands the severity and the the
Russian spy has been caught by the
mother but but the US government says
yes and then the Tom Hanks character
asks aren't you worried and he says
would it help in response so he's full
yeah you've articulated much better than
me no but you brought but you brought it
up and the lesson is I think very
apropos of the moment that we find
ourselves in and that is you can be
informed to the extent that it's
relevant to your lives in action a ball
you can be aware without being paralyzed
by pessimism and worry not to say that I
don't struggle I have struggled in the
last few weeks but it is in fact
possible to be aware and informed
without being paralyzed and that that's
something that I'm certainly striving
for myself and so I to that and I
appreciate the the reminder it is a
fantastic scene and David this has been
such a pleasure I I really appreciate
you taking the time especially during
these times when you are you are you're
an example and an inspiration to so many
people and I'm very flattered to occupy
your your extraordinary mind for a brief
period of time and hopefully we can we
can we can just add to it when when I
says you but I'm very flattered and
humbled to to be part of this exchange
absolutely and want one final question
when you got hammered in celebration
after you were represented by your Palm
Beach man with no name tastemaker
what was your drink of choice or drinks
of choice for that evening I think it
would be quite a quite a big range that
would take up another 20 minutes to
discuss the the is breath but I think
the thing is if you're Scott
you live under this belief that there's
a mass conspiracy around the rest of the
world to conceal how wonderful the
nation is and it just hasn't got out so
when we when we go abroad and we got a
America we just have to we have to drink
a lot of scotch well a single malt
scotch and then talk to the barman that
we're actually that's where we're from
it's my it's my head's of patriotism and
said my lucky good scotch and maybe when
I'm in Austin we can we can share a
scotch deal I would love to do that and
David again thank you for the time to be
continued and for everybody listening
thank you for tuning in be safe out
there
practice well hold yourselves to a high
standard but try to be forgiving also if
you struggle during these times in
particular and I will include links to
everything we've discussed including all
of David's work that we can link to
without violating any types of
intellectual property and we will
showcase everything that we talked about
in this conversation at Tim dot blog
forward slash podcast where you'll be
able to find the show notes so alongside
show notes for every other episode and
until next time thanks for listening hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is bible at friday do you want to
get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email for me every
friday event provides a little morsel of
fun before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles the
red and that I've shared with my close
friends for instance and it's very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that check it out
just go to 4-hour workweek
Don come that's 4-hour workweek dot-com
all spelled out and just drop in your
email and you will get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
LegalZoom it's a whole new world out
there and we're all facing new
challenges you may need legal help to
overcome some of wars and that's where
Legal Zoom fits in maybe you've been
wondering what the best way to protect
your family or maybe you're thinking
about starting a business but you don't
know the best way to do it
don't let legal questions hold you back
Legal Zoom has been dedicated to helping
you find the right solutions for nearly
twenty years you're looking to protect
your family with a bill or living trust
or something else or you're thinking
about the right way to start a business
with the LLC the profit or more legal
zooms got you covered it's easy to get
started online and if you need guidance
their network of attorneys can provide
advice to ensure you make the right
choices since Legal Zoom isn't a law
firm you won't get charged by the hour
let's check it out visit legalzoom.com
today to take care of the important
things that need to get done that's
legalzoom.com legal zone your life needs
legal this episode is brought to you by
thrive market thrive market saves me a
ton of money and it's perfect for these
crazy times thrive market is a
membership-based site on a mission to
make healthy living easy and affordable
for everyone you can regularly save 25
to 50% off of your normal retail prices
with memorable prices for anything you
can imagine
really whether it's key to open a Leo
gluten-free vegan whatever you can sort
by that you can find all types of food
you can find supplements you can find
non-toxic home products clean line dog
food just about anything and let me give
you a personal example of just how much
you can save so my last order
I ordered rival Kitchen mayonnaise we
just made with avocado oil it's
delicious Justin's almond butter and the
first was 25 percent off the Justin's
almond butter was 30 percent off raus
homemade marinara sauce which is awesome
26 percent off
all said and done at the end of my
shopping I saved $39 on my order so
members and I'm a member can earn
wholesale prices every day and save an
average of $30 on each order I'll come
back to that and through thrive gives
their one-on-one membership matching
program every paid to thrive market
membership is matched with a free one
for a low income family in need and you
can try thrive market a few different
ways they have the monthly membership
which is 995 per month they have the
12-month membership for five dollars a
month which is billed at fifty nine
ninety five and right now this is
exclusive you guys you can get up to a
$20.00 shopping credit when you join
today now remember that I save thirty
nine dollars on my order so basically
with one or two orders I pay for the
annual membership which is pretty sweet
so go to thrive market dot-com forward
slash Tim to give thrive market try you
can like I said choose between the
membership models you'd like to test out
if it doesn't work for you you can
cancel for any reason within thirty days
for a full refund and on top of that you
will make FAC your membership and
savings as I have or they give you
credits to make up for the difference so
it's really win win-win all around
and I would suggest to check it out go
to thrive market calm phone / Tim you
can receive up to $20.00 in shopping
credit that's thrive market compote /
Tim for up to $20.00 and shopping credit
plus all of the other great stuff than I
mentioned one more time check it out
thrive market calm forward slash temp
[Applause]